This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Matthew Taylor is a lawyer in Southern California. He runs a small law firm. We have a total of five people working here. And specializes in defending employees from unfair practices in the workplace. So, Matthew thinks a lot about employees. What makes them unhappy? What makes them tick?
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。马修·泰勒是南加州的一名律师。他经营着一家小型律师事务所。我们这里总共只有五个人工作。并且专门负责在职场中为员工辩护，对抗不公正的做法。所以，马修经常为员工着想。是什么让他们不高兴？是什么在驱动着他们？
We're in contact with each other for eight hours a day, five days a week. And so it's real helpful if people are happy with each other. And he asked himself how he could make his employees happier. Matthew's firm gives out holiday bonuses at the end of the year. And it's not reflective specifically on their performance.
我们每天联系八个小时，一周五天。所以如果大家对彼此感到满意，那真的很有帮助。于是他问自己，怎样才能让他的员工更开心。马修的公司在年底会发放节日奖金。而且这并不具体反映他们的工作表现。
Matthew decided to tinker with the system. In addition to the bonuses at the end of the year, what if people got bonuses throughout the year? They would be smaller, of course, but would provide a steady stream of appreciation. Matthew also put in place a second idea, a radical idea. What if instead of having a manager decide who got the bonuses, employees awarded bonuses directly to one another. The peer bonus system was a system that as we put it in place allows any of the people in the office to give a cash bonus to any of the other people in the office. Matthew figured that if anyone
马修决定对这个制度进行调整。除了年底的奖金之外，如果大家在一年当中也能拿到奖金会怎么样？当然，这些奖金会少一些，但能提供源源不断的认可。马修还实施了第二个想法，一个激进的想法。如果不是由经理来决定谁拿奖金，而是由员工直接互相颁发奖金会怎么样？同伴奖金制度正如我们所实施的那样，允许办公室里的任何人向办公室里的其他人发放现金奖金。马修认为，如果说有人
knew about a worker's accomplishments or how hard an employee was working on a project, it would be her co-workers. The fact that Leoni got acknowledged for when she passed her notary certificate program and got her notary license, although I knew what happened, I probably wouldn't have thought about it for a specific bonus. And I know that Maria had received one for work on a particular project from another person who was on the project.
了解一个员工的成就，或者了解一个员工在某个项目上付出了多大努力，那一定是她的同事。事实上，莉奥尼通过公证员证书项目并获得公证员执照时得到了认可，虽然我知道这件事发生过，但我可能不会专门为它考虑发放奖金。而且我知道玛丽亚曾因参与某个项目而从该项目的另一位成员那里获得过奖金。
And although I know that they were both working on the project, I didn't realize how much work Maria had done. The bonuses were only a hundred bucks a piece, but Maria Garcia, a legal assistant in the office, says she likes getting a pat on the back from a colleague. I love the recognition, I love not so much what the dollar amount is, but heck, getting the bonus, let me take my family to dinner.
虽然我知道他们两个都在参与这个项目，但我并没有意识到玛丽亚做了那么多工作。这些奖金每笔只有一百块钱，但办公室里的法律助理玛丽亚·加西亚说，她喜欢得到同事的认可。我喜欢这种认可，我倒不在乎具体的金额是多少，但拿到奖金太棒了，我可以带家人去吃晚餐。
The idea for this bonus program came from another workplace, one of the most famous workplaces in the world. Google, people innovate more, they stick around at the company longer, they seem happier, and honestly, the happiness by itself is enough of a result. That's kind of the right thing to do in the right way to treat people. This is Lazlo Bach, head of Google's People Operations, that's Google Speak for a Human Resources Department. Matthew got the idea for the Peer Bonus System from Lazlo's book, Work Rules, which is all about how organizations can find and keep talented people. It starts with a presumption or an assumption that people are fundamentally good and that people will kind of do better stuff if they feel like it's theirs. Today we're going to take a deep dive into these ideas with Lazlo Bach, who joins me now. Lazlo, welcome to Hidden Brain.
这个奖金项目的想法来自于另一个工作场所，世界上最著名的工作场所之一。谷歌，人们更有创新精神，在公司呆的时间更长，看起来更快乐，老实说，快乐本身就是一个足够好的结果。这可以说是正确的事情，也是对待人们的正确方式。这是谷歌人事运营主管拉斯洛·巴克，也就是谷歌对人力资源部门的称呼。马修关于同伴奖金制度的想法来自于拉斯洛的书《工作规则》，这本书讲的全是如何找到并留住有才华的人。它始于一个假设，即人们本质上是善良的，如果人们觉得那是他们自己的东西，他们就会做得更好。今天我们将与拉斯洛·巴克深入探讨这些想法，他现在加入了我们的节目。拉斯洛，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。
Oh it's fantastic to be here. I'm a huge fan of the show. Thank you. You've looked at a lot of companies outside of Google and down history that have in many ways invented the template for what you do at Google. So in your book, you mentioned Bell Labs and Henry Ford, a number of other examples. What do these companies do vis-à-vis their employees that caught your eye? Well, there's a few things that I'd actually add, even the US military, to the list. One
哦，很高兴来到这里。我是这个节目的超级粉丝。谢谢你。你研究了谷歌之外的许多公司，以及历史上在很多方面为你所做的事情奠定模板的公司。所以在你的书中，你提到了贝尔实验室和亨利·福特，还有许多其他例子。这些公司对员工做了什么引起了你的注意？嗯，实际上我还想把美国军队列入这个名单，有几件事。一
thing is, if you take a look at Bell Labs, for example, the way they thought about how time was spent and how space was arrayed and how people interacted was amazing and inspiring. So when they built the buildings that Bell Labs were in, they set up the buildings where there's a long corridor down this long building and all the offices were off to the sides.
个是，如果你看看贝尔实验室，例如，他们思考时间如何分配、空间如何排列以及人们如何互动的方式是令人惊叹和鼓舞人心的。所以在他们建造贝尔实验室所在的建筑时，他们将建筑设计成长长的走廊，所有的办公室都在两侧。
And the thesis was people would kind of stumble out of their offices and bump into each other and have interesting conversations. There's a direct line from that to the way, for example, at Google, we run our cafes where we have these round tables and long tables where you end up sitting next to strangers and bumping into them. And we try to manufacture these moments of serendipity in much the way Bell labs did. If you look at the US Army, for example, they've been doing all kinds of testing around,
其核心论点是，人们会摇摇晃晃地走出办公室，互相碰撞，并进行有趣的对话。从那到我们在谷歌运营咖啡馆的方式，有着直接的联系，我们在那里设立了圆桌和长桌，最后你会和陌生人坐在一起并与他们擦肩而过。我们试图以贝尔实验室大致相同的方式来制造这些偶遇的时刻。如果你看看美国陆军，例如，几十年来，他们一直在围绕
what are the right kinds of recruits, what kind of jobs should they get in, for decades and decades and decades and looking hard at questions of leadership. And how do you take someone who on paper has a high school education at most, in many cases, and turn them into leaders? And so we look to those two as models of,
正确的应征者是什么样的，他们应该从事什么样的工作，进行各种各样的测试，并深入研究领导力问题。你如何把一个在纸面上最多只有高中学历（在许多情况下）的人变成领导者？所以我们将这两者视为模型，
how do you take raw material? It's just people you find, and make them exceptional. You talk at length in your book about the importance of getting employees to think of themselves not as employees, but almost as founders, as owners of the enterprise. You walk me through how you try and find ways to get employees at Google to feel like they are founders and owners as opposed to employees.
如何对待原材料？这只是你找到的人，然后让他们变得非凡。你在书中详细谈到了让员工不把自己当成雇员，而是几乎当成创始人和企业所有者的重要性。你能带我了解一下你是如何尝试寻找方法让谷歌的员工觉得自己是创始人和所有者，而不是雇员的吗？
Well, there's a few things. And it starts with a presumption or an assumption that people are fundamentally good and that people will kind of do better stuff if they feel like it's theirs. Just the same way that people take better care of their personal car than a rental car. So there's a number of things we do at the company to try to instill that one is we literally make everyone owners When you join Google no matter what the job no matter where in the world everyone gets stock and at our size That's actually pretty unusual most companies that are size stop giving stock to everybody. We think it's important The second thing is being transparent with people about what happens in the company and why. So we have a weekly all hands that are CEO Sundar Pachai hosts with Larry and
嗯，有几件事。它始于一个假设，即人们本质上是善良的，如果人们觉得那是他们自己的东西，他们就会做得更好。就像人们爱护自己的私家车胜过租来的车一样。所以我们在公司里做了很多事情来试图灌输这一点，其中之一就是我们真正让每个人都成为所有者。当你加入谷歌时，无论什么工作，无论在世界的哪个角落，每个人都能获得股票。以我们的规模来说，这实际上非常罕见，大多数我们这个规模的公司都不再向所有人发放股票。我们认为这很重要。第二件事是向人们透明地公开公司里发生了什么以及原因。所以我们有一个每周全员大会，由我们的首席执行官桑达尔·皮查伊与拉里和
Sir Gare founders, where you can ask any question, you get updates on what's happening in the company, tremendous amounts of information are shared. Everyone's goals in the company are visible to everybody else. And the idea is, again, if it's your thing, you should know what's going on with it. And then finally, we have a lot of vehicles where people can exert their freedom, feel ownership for things. We give them a lot of channels to express voice,
谢尔盖（两位创始人）共同主持，在那里你可以问任何问题，了解公司正在发生的事情的最新进展，会分享大量的信息。公司里每个人的目标对其他所有人都是可见的。我们的想法依然是，如果这是你的事情，你就应该知道它正在发生什么。最后，我们有很多途径让人们发挥他们的自由，对事物产生主人翁感。我们为他们提供了很多表达心声的渠道，
whether it's through the particular ways we kind of do surveys or ask people for input, but also by encouraging people to feel like the company is less hierarchical. We have 62,000 employees, and the company's gonna feel like the company is less hierarchical. We have 62,000 employees, and the company's gonna feel like a large organization. People are gonna come in being sensitive to,
无论是通过我们进行调查的特定方式，还是向人们征求意见，也通过鼓励人们觉得公司的层级观念不那么重。我们有62,000名员工，公司会让人觉得层级没那么重。我们有62,000名员工，公司会感觉像是一个大型组织。人们进来时会对以下情况敏感：
well, if somebody has a fancy title or if they're the founder, I should be careful and probably not reach out to them. And instead we encourage them and say, look, if something's going wrong, drop a note to Larry, drop a note to Sundar, reach out to anybody, because where you sit in the hierarchy doesn't matter.
如果某人有华丽的头衔或者他们是创始人，我应该小心，可能不应该去联系他们。相反，我们鼓励他们并说，听着，如果有什么不对劲，给拉里留个便条，给桑达尔留个便条，联系任何人，因为你在层级中的位置并不重要。
It's all of our thing. It's all of our organization and we all have an obligation to make it better. Because of course this is what happens at many organizations. People in the front lines see things that actually are not working as well as they should or see things that could be made better. They are on the front lines and they actually have insights into how to make them better, but they often feel time-eared or frustrated or impotent to actually send those signals to others in the organization and actually see change happen.
这是我们所有人的事情。这是我们所有人的组织，我们所有人都有义务把它变得更好。因为这当然是许多组织中发生的事情。一线人员看到了实际上运作得不够好的事情，或者看到了可以改进的事情。他们身处一线，并且确实对如何改进它们有独到的见解，但他们经常感到时间紧迫、沮丧或无能为力，无法将这些信号真正发送给组织中的其他人，也无法真正看到改变的发生。
You're absolutely right. I mean, it's kind of a truism and business set. The people who actually know what's going on are the ones who are touching your users, touching your customers, touching your advertisers. They see truth. And the bigger you are, the harder it is for that to get filtered up through the organization. But you want those people to just fix it. So for example, we have a team that works with our small and medium
你完全说得对。我的意思是，这是一个商业常识。真正知道发生了什么的人是那些接触你们的用户、接触你们的客户、接触你们的广告商的人。他们看到了真相。而且你们的规模越大，这些信息通过组织向上过滤就越困难。但你希望这些人能够直接解决问题。例如，我们有一个团队与我们的小型和中型
customers, our advertisers. So these are mom and pop shots, florists and bakers and bootmakers and what have you. And a young woman working on one of these teams was helping a customer figure out how to do their advertising better, which would in turn generate more business, help them grow, and finish the call by saying, is there anything else I can do for you? And this small business owner said, well, I'm kind of hungry, it's lunchtime. Can you order me a pizza? That's right, that's good question.
客户即我们的广告商合作。所以这些都是夫妻店、花店、面包店、鞋匠之类的人。在这些团队中工作的一名年轻女性正在帮助一位客户弄清楚如何更好地做广告，这反过来会产生更多的业务，帮助他们成长，并在结束通话时说，还有什么我可以帮你做的吗？这位小企业主说，嗯，我有点饿了，现在是午餐时间。你能帮我点个披萨吗？没错，这是一个好问题。
I mean, she asked. So she ordered him a pizza. And she didn't need to get approval. She didn't need to do anything like check with a manager at cost 12 or 15 bucks, whatever it cost. That guy who received that pizza, he tells that story all over the place. He remembers that.
我的意思是，她问了。所以她给他点了一个披萨。她不需要获得批准。她不需要像跟经理核对那样做任何事情，花了12或15美元，无论花了多少钱。那个收到披萨的家伙，他到处讲这个故事。他记得这件事。
That's a cool, unexpected thing. But it's because she felt like I'm helping him, I'm helping his business. And my job is to do the right thing. And that's a small ask. Let me take care of it for him. So one of the ways you get this done at Google is that you actually take away power from managers.
这是一件很酷的、意料之外的事情。但这是因为她觉得我在帮他，我在帮他的生意。我的工作就是做正确的事。这是一个小要求。让我为他处理好它。所以你在谷歌实现这一目标的途径之一，实际上是剥夺经理们的权力。
And this is sort of a radical idea. Because when you think about what managers do, managers have power over the people who report to them. And Google systematically tries to deprive managers of that kind of power. Talk about that idea and the potential problems it creates in addition to the benefits it creates. Well, the benefits are people are happier and more productive and they do better things. I mean, if you think about it, it's an amazing thing. As an employee and we are all employees, what do we
这是一个相当激进的想法。因为当你思考经理们做什么时，经理对向他们汇报的人拥有权力。而谷歌系统性地试图剥夺经理们的这种权力。谈谈这个想法，以及它除了带来的好处之外所潜在的问题。嗯，好处是人们更快乐、更高效，他们做得更好。我的意思是，如果你仔细想想，这是一件了不起的事情。作为一名员工——我们都是员工——我们
want? We want to be left alone. We just want to get our work done. We're going to do a good job. We want to get it done when we need it done in the way we want to get it done, but we're going to do the right thing and we're going to do high quality work typically if left to our own devices. Again, if you believe people are good and most of them are. And then as a manager, suddenly you want different things because you're on the hook for other people's work. So the default reaction, the very human reaction is, I'm going to control you, I'm going to tell you what to do. I got a micromanage to make sure things work out the way I want them to work. But what's crazy is when we're
想要什么？我们希望被独自留下。我们只想完成我们的工作。我们要做好工作。我们想在需要的时候以我们想要的方式完成它，但如果我们顺其自然，我们通常会做正确的事情，并且会做高质量的工作。再说一次，如果你相信人们是善良的，而且大多数人确实如此。然后作为一名经理，你突然想要不同的东西，因为你要对其他人的工作负责。所以默认的反应、非常符合人性的反应是，我要控制你，我要告诉你该做什么。我必须进行微观管理，以确保事情按照我想要的方式发展。但疯狂的是，当我们成为
managers, we're also still employees. So we're feeling both these conflicting things and we default to what, you know, our culture, our heredity, our DNA, whatever, tells us which is I'm going to control down, but I want freedom up. And if you take that away and instead tell managers, your job is to make teams effective, they're going to do the right thing, you just coach them, you counsel them. And the way we do it is managers don't get to decide who they promote, they don't get to make pay decisions unilaterally, they don't get to decide who they promote. They don't get to make pay decisions unilaterally. They don't get to choose who goes on their team.
经理时，我们其实也还是员工。所以我们感受着这两种相互冲突的事情，我们默认听从我们的文化、我们的遗传、我们的DNA或其他什么告诉我们的东西，那就是向下控制，但向上渴望自由。如果你把权力拿走，转而告诉经理，你的工作是让团队变得有效率，他们会做正确的事，你只需要指导他们，辅导他们。我们采用的方式是，经理无权决定谁晋升，他们不能单方面做出薪酬决定，他们无权决定谁晋升。他们不能单方面做出薪酬决定。他们无权选择谁进入他们的团队。
They don't get to choose who they hire. All that's done by separate committees at Google, made up of other managers and other employees who make those calls. The effect is, as a manager, the only tools you're left with are, how can I help? And when you come to edit from that mindset, you actually make your teams better, because what they're looking for from you
他们无权选择他们雇用谁。所有这些都由谷歌的独立委员会完成，这些委员会由其他经理和其他员工组成，由他们做出这些决定。其效果是，作为一名经理，你剩下的唯一工具是：“我能帮什么忙？”当你抱着这种心态去处理问题时，你实际上会让你的团队变得更好，因为他们从你这里寻找的
is not control, but guidance and support and coaching. And the more carrots you use and the fewer sticks you have, the easier that's going to be. So those are the benefits. And what we find is people innovate more, they stick around at the company longer, they seem happier. And honestly, the happiness by itself
不是控制，而是指导、支持和辅导。你使用的胡萝卜越多，你拥有的棍棒越少，事情就会越容易。所以这些是好处。我们发现的是，人们更有创新精神，在公司呆的时间更长，他们看起来更快乐。老实说，快乐本身
is enough of a result. That's kind of the right thing to do in the right way to treat people. What's the downside? Well, the downside is if you're trying to drive a big, big change, it can be a little slower because it's harder in our culture to say, you know what, we're going to do whatever it is
就是一个足够好的结果。这可以说是正确的事情，也是对待人们的正确方式。有什么缺点呢？嗯，缺点是如果你想推动一个重大变革，它可能会慢一点，因为在我们的文化中很难说，你知道吗，我们要这样做
and we're going to force this through the organization. We took a run at having a social-based product, Google Plus, a number of years ago, and it was hard to sort of get the whole company to focus on this thing, and our results were not great, and there were some great things we learned, but overall, it could have gone better. And it's in part because you've got to convince all these people that this is a big deal and then make sure you have the right idea and make sure it happens in the right way. That takes time. Now a lot of people I think who are workers and employees will find lots to like in your book,
并将其强行推行到整个组织中。几年前，我们尝试过推出一款基于社交的产品Google Plus，让整个公司都专注于这件事很困难，我们的结果并不理想，我们学到了一些极好的东西，但总的来说，本可以做得更好。部分原因在于你必须说服所有人这是一件大事，然后确保你有正确的想法，并确保它以正确的方式发生。这需要时间。现在我认为很多身为工人和员工的人会在你的书里找到很多喜欢的东西，
but you also have some ideas that might not be as well received. So for one thing, you believe that wide variations in pay among employees might actually be a good thing. You believe in what's sometimes called the power law distribution in salary. Yeah, that's right. And not just salary and bonus and in our case in stock grants. So the thesis is normally people assume human performance is normally distributed. You've got kind of a top half, a bottom half,
但你也有一些可能不会那么受欢迎的想法。比如，你认为员工之间薪酬的巨大差异实际上可能是一件好事。你相信有时被称为薪酬幂律分布的东西。是的，没错。不仅仅是薪酬和奖金，在我们的案例中还有股票期权。所以核心论点是，通常人们假设人类的表现呈正态分布。你有一个上半部分，一个下半部分，
and then there's these, within those there's these tails. And you might have 5% or 10% at the top, 5% or 10% at the bottom. And their performance actually looks like that. In reality, we all hear about the 80-20 rule where 20% of your people generate 80% of your value in a lot of fields, including software engineering, but also in sales and marketing. Your top people generate way more value.
然后在这其中有这些尾部。你可能会在顶部有5%或10%，在底部有5%或10%。他们的表现实际上看起来就是这样。实际上，我们都听说过80/20法则，在许多领域（包括软件工程，还有销售和市场营销），20%的人创造了80%的价值。你最顶尖的人才创造了多得多的价值。
And the academic research shows that in profession after profession, the very best people are so much better than average that they actually generate 90, 95, 98% of the value or the wins in particular areas. So what that means is, if you're paying everyone, assuming that you're very best people are only 10 or 20% better than average when really they're 50 or 100 or 200 or 500%. You're underpaying your best people. And the effect of that is they're going to want to quit because the market will work over time and they're going to go someplace else where they can get that money. So instead what you have to do is number one, pay really aggressively for high performance
学术研究表明，在各行各业中，最优秀的人才比平均水平要好得多，以至于他们在特定领域实际上创造了90%、95%、98%的价值或成功。所以这意味着，如果你假设最优秀的人才只比平均水平好10%或20%，而实际上他们好50%、100%、200%或500%，并以此向所有人支付薪酬，你就是在给最优秀的人才支付过低的薪酬。这样做的后果是他们会想要辞职，因为市场会随着时间发挥作用，他们会去其他能拿到这笔钱的地方。所以相反，你必须做的是，第一，为高绩效支付极具攻击性的薪酬
but number two, you need a system that is just and fair so that you actually can honestly stand in front of your employees and say, this is why this person got that much money. This is what it looks like and do that in a way that's honorable and ethical and honest, and then employees can look at and go, okay, I understand the path from where I am to that and the system works and here's how I move up in the system. When we come back, I'm going to ask Lazlo Bach about one of the most important parts of his job, finding and spotting great talent. Stay with us.
但第二，你需要一个公正公平的系统，这样你才能真正诚实地站在员工面前说：“这就是这个人拿到这么多钱的原因。”这就是它的样子，并以一种光荣、符合道德且诚实的方式做到这一点，然后员工看后会觉得：“好吧，我理解从我现在的状态到那种状态的路径，这个系统运作良好，这就是我在系统中晋升的方式。”当我们回来时，我将询问拉斯洛·巴克关于他工作中最重要的部分之一：寻找和发掘伟大的人才。请不要走开。
We'd like to say a quick thank you and share a message from one of our sponsors AT&T. With the rate of change increasing, businesses today need the agility to do one thing and another. And no one knows and, like AT&T. Their network and solutions are helping companies sense and adapt to meet the demands of business, making them more open to innovation and more secure from threats. In the cloud and on the ground, that's the power of and. Support for Hidden Brain also comes from Wells Fargo.
我们想对我们的赞助商之一AT&T表示诚挚的谢意，并分享一条来自他们的信息。随着变革速度的加快，当今的企业需要具备同时做好多件事情的灵活性。没有人比AT&T更懂“兼顾”。他们的网络和解决方案正在帮助企业感知并适应商业需求，使他们对创新更开放，对威胁更安全。无论是在云端还是在地面，这就是“兼顾”的力量。对Hidden Brain的支持还来自富国银行。
Wells Fargo understands that you work hard to get the most out of life. From starting a business to saving for retirement, there are a lot of things you want to accomplish. Working together, Wells Fargo will take the time to understand what you're trying to achieve to help you reach your financial goals. That way you can care for the people and things that matter most. Learn more at WellsFargo.com slash together. WellsFargo together will go far. Check out the MPR-1 app for your phone. You can use it to listen to it in brain. And it's a great way to find tons of new shows and stories too.
富国银行深知你努力工作是为了充分享受生活。从创业到为退休储蓄，有很多事情你想去完成。通过齐心协力，富国银行将花时间了解你的追求，以帮助你实现财务目标。这样你就可以照顾最重要的人和事。请访问WellsFargo.com/together了解更多信息。富国银行，携手致远。请在手机上查看NPR-1应用程序。你可以用它来收听Hidden Brain。这也是发现大量新节目和故事的好方法。
Great stories are always ready when you are on MPR-1. Find it in the App Store now. store now. Last little buck, I want to spend some time talking about hiring people. Google spends an enormous amount of time recruiting the best talent. Walk me through the evolution of your thinking on how you go about finding the most talented people. Well, it's been a work in progress. I don't think we're done yet.
当你准备好时，NPR-1总有好故事随时相伴。立即在App Store中找到它。立即在应用商店中找到它。拉斯洛·巴克，我想花点时间谈谈招聘员工。谷歌花了大量时间来招募最优秀的人才。请带我了解你关于如何寻找最有才华的人的思维演变过程。嗯，这是一个进行中的工作。我认为我们还没完成。
But it started from the constraint to the company's growth in the early years, even before I joined, was how quickly can we hire people? That was the biggest constraint on Google's growth was finding great people quickly. And we took a very brute force approach and kind of a naive approach. We said, let's just have as many recruiters as we can,
但它始于公司早期的增长限制，甚至在我加入之前，那就是我们能以多快的速度雇佣员工？这是谷歌增长的最大限制，即快速找到优秀的人才。我们采取了一种非常简单粗暴的方法，或者说有点天真的方法。我们说，让我们拥有尽可能多的招聘人员，
talk to as many people as we can, and let's start with all the fancy schools that we quote unquote know are the places where the smartest people are. And by the way, let's screen for smarts because we're smart people and that's what makes people successful. So that's what we thought. We hit a point where we found that we couldn't find people fast enough that the people we were hiring weren't always performing as well as we thought.
与尽可能多的人交谈，让我们从所有我们“知道”是聪明人所在的那些高端学校开始。顺便说一句，让我们筛选聪明才智，因为我们是聪明人，这才是让人成功的原因。所以我们就是这么想的。我们遇到了一个瓶颈，我们发现我们无法足够快地找到人，我们雇佣的人并不总是像我们想象的那样表现出色。
And people we were interviewing were just having awful experiences. When I moved to Silicon Valley, my cab driver, my real estate agent, the checkout clerk at the grocery store, everyone when they saw I was wearing a Google t-shirt would say, let me tell you about this person, I know who had a terrible experience interviewing with Google. So we did a whole bunch of things and are still on this journey to get better at it. But for example, we looked at how many interviews do you need to actually be able to tell whether or not to hire somebody. We've been doing 15 to 25 interviews per candidate.
我们面试的人有着糟糕的体验。当我搬到硅谷时，我的出租车司机、我的房地产经纪人、杂货店的收银员，每个人看到我穿着一件谷歌T恤时都会说：“让我跟你讲讲这个人，我知道有个家伙在谷歌面试时有糟糕的体验。”所以我们做了很多事情，并且仍在为做得更好而努力。例如，我们研究了你需要多少次面试才能真正判断是否应该雇佣某人。我们曾经对每个候选人进行15到25次面试。
Turns out after four, we got a pretty good sense of who we should hire. We used to look at academic pedigree a lot. Where were your test scores? Where'd you go to school? Turns out, it doesn't really matter. Your undergraduate performance is a little predictive of your first two years of professional performance, but beyond that, none of the stuff matters. And you can find amazing people, as many of your listeners will know, at state schools or without degrees. But at Google, we just hadn't learned that lesson. We started kind of naively with what our gut told us and our gut was wrong. So since then you've actually changed and you're looking for different things.
事实证明，在4次之后，我们对应该雇佣谁有了相当不错的直觉。我们过去非常看重学术背景。你的考试分数是多少？你在哪里上过学？事实证明，这其实并不重要。你的本科表现能在一定程度上预测你前两年的专业表现，但除此之外，这些东西都不重要。正如你们的听众所知，你可以在州立大学或没有学位的人当中找到优秀的人才。但在谷歌，我们只是还没吸取这个教训。我们以直觉告诉我们的那种天真的方式开始，而我们的直觉是错的。所以从那以后你真的改变了，你在寻找不同的东西。
So when someone walks in the door, what is it that Google looks for right now? Yeah, maybe one of the biggest changes to our recruiting and interviewing process has been rather than just sort of asking brain teasers and problem solvers and all these questions that we thought screened for pure IQ. We actually went back and looked at what are the characteristics of people who've been successful at the company and at other places. And why don't we screen for that instead of using crazy brain teasers or problem solving like why our manhole covers around asking what are called structured interview questions, which are actually proven in the academic research to be an accurate way of predicting how someone's going
那么当有人走进大门时，谷歌现在寻找的是什么？是的，也许我们招聘和面试流程中最大的变化之一，不是只去问脑筋急转弯、问题解决者和所有我们认为能筛选出纯IQ的问题。我们实际上回过头去研究了公司内外部成功人士的特征是什么。为什么我们不筛选这些特征，而不是使用疯狂的脑筋急转弯或问题解决测试（比如为什么人孔盖是圆的），而是问所谓的结构化面试题目，这些题目在学术研究中已被证明是预测一个人表现准确的方法。
to perform. And we boiled it down to four attributes. General cognitive ability. So that's smart, but it also relates to learning ability and general problem solving, not just how did you do on your SAT. The second thing is what we call emergent leadership. So it's not where you kept it of a football team, where you promoted device president quickly. It's when you see a problem, do you step in to help fix it and just as importantly do
我们将它们归纳为四个属性。一般认知能力。所以这不仅是聪明，它还与学习能力和一般问题解决能力有关，不仅关乎你的SAT考得怎么样。第二件事是我们所说的突发性领导力。所以这不是你当过橄榄球队队长，或者快速晋升为副总裁。而是当你看到问题时，你会不会介入帮忙解决，同样重要的是，你是否会
relinquish power and let go of it. The third is what we call Googliness. And it's kind of a silly word, but basically what it boils down to is conscientiousness, which gets to this question of what people think like owners once they're here. And the second element of Googleiness is intellectual humility. Not real humility. We have people with big personalities and sometimes bruising personalities, but the kind of humility that lets you say, if I get new facts, I'm going to revise my opinions and perspectives in light
放弃权力并放手。第三个是我们所说的“谷歌范儿”（Googliness）。这是一个有点傻的词，但基本上它归结为尽责性，这回到了前面提到的问题：人们在这里时是否像所有者一样思考。谷歌范儿的第二个要素是智识谦逊。不是真正的谦逊。我们有性格鲜明甚至有时锋芒毕露的人，但这种谦逊能让你说：如果我获得了新的事实，我将根据这些新事实修正我的观点和看法。
of those new facts. That's what we look for. And then the last and least important thing is actually, can you do the job? Because we figure if you have all the other attributes, you'll figure out the job and maybe you'll come up with something new that the world hasn't seen before. You must wonder though, from time to time, whether you're missing great people. So, you know, if you were to run a thought experiment and Larry Page and Sergey Brin, the founders of Google, showed up to be recruited. Do you think they would be recruited at Google? Would you? I think they would. Yeah, I'm not so sure. Well, it's interesting because what you're touching on is this question of sample bias. We're only looking at people who we've hired
这就是我们所寻找的。然后最后也是最不重要的一点实际上是：你能胜任这份工作吗？因为我们认为，如果你具备所有其他属性，你会弄清楚这项工作，也许你会想出一些这个世界以前从未见过的新东西。不过你一定时不时会想，自己是否错过了伟大的人才。所以，如果你做一个思想实验，谷歌的创始人拉里·佩奇和谢尔盖·布林出现来应聘。你认为他们会被谷歌录用吗？你会吗？我想他们会的。是的，我可不那么确定。嗯，这很有趣，因为你触及的是样本偏差的问题。我们只看那些我们在谷歌
at Google. Are we overlooking a whole bunch of people that we should be hiring? And so I'd say first of all, we've tried to widen the span of who we look at and where we look. So for example, over the last two years, we went from recruiting at about 150 different campuses, just in the US, to over 450. And we expanded dramatically to places like the historically black colleges and universities
录用的人。我们是否忽略了一大批我们应该录用的人？所以我首先要说的是，我们试图扩大我们考察的人员范围和地点。例如，在过去两年里，我们招聘的校园范围从仅在美国的大约150个，扩大到450多个。我们戏剧性地扩展到了诸如历史上黑人学院和大学（HBCU）
like Howard, to historically heavily Latino universities, we increased our outreach to veterans communities. Precisely because our sense was, we're missing great people. And it wasn't just because it felt like the right thing to do, though it does, but it was also because we just need to find more people. And we're hiring like crazy and growing quickly, and we don't want to overlook people. And we still got a ways to go on that. But the second thing was, we looked at where they're people who we had interviewed, that we rejected, that we should not have rejected,
如霍华德大学，以及历史上拉丁裔占多数的大学，我们增加了对退伍军人群体的 outreach（外展服务）。正是因为我们的直觉是：我们在错过优秀的人才。这不仅仅是因为感觉这是正确的事（尽管确实如此），也是因为我们需要找到更多的人。我们在疯狂地招聘并快速成长，我们不想忽视人才。在这方面我们还有很长的路要走。但第二件事是，我们查看了是否有一些我们面试过但拒绝了的人，是我们本不该拒绝的，
and should we go back and hire them. So, for a number of years, we actually would ask candidates in the application process a few questions, five to ten questions, that turned out to be, because of analysis we've done prior to that, we knew would predict performance. And so if somebody was rejected by a hiring process, but they scored well on these five to 10 questions, we would go ahead and hire them and put them in jobs.
我们是否应该回去雇用他们。因此，多年来，我们在申请流程中实际上会向候选人问几个问题，5到10个问题，由于我们之前做过分析，我们知道这些问题可以预测绩效。所以如果某人在招聘流程中被拒绝了，但他们在这些5到10个问题上得分很高，我们会继续雇用他们并安排他们工作。
And what we saw was, indeed, these people performed as well or better than people going through our traditional process. And so we changed our process to make sure we were scooping up these people we were otherwise overlooking. What kind of questions were you asking them? Well, one, for example, was we would ask on a scale of 1 to 5, rate yourself as a software engineer. And it turns out that if you're a man, the correct answer, the most predictive of success
我们看到的是，确实，这些人的表现与经历我们传统流程的人一样好甚至更好。所以我们改变了流程，以确保我们能网罗到这些原本会被我们忽视的人。你当时问他们什么样的问题？嗯，其中一个例子是，我们会要求在1到5的量表上，为自己作为软件工程师的水平打分。事实证明，如果你是一个男人，最能预测成功的正确答案是：
was I would rate myself a 4 on a scale of 1 to 5. And our hypothesis is that's because men tend to overestimate their capabilities on average, men tend to be not a self-aware on average as women, and for a man to say 4 was a signal, not the only one, but a signal that maybe this guy is a little more self-aware, maybe he realizes he has something to learn, and that was positively correlated with success here. If you were a woman, however, the score that was most predictive
在1到5的量表上，我会给自己打4分。我们的假设是，这是因为男人的平均能力评估倾向于过高，男人的平均自我意识往往不如女性，对于一个男人来说，说4分是一个信号（不是唯一的信号，但也是一个信号），表明这个家伙可能更有自我意识，可能他意识到自己还有东西要学，这与这里的成功呈正相关。然而，如果你是一个女人，最能预测成功的得分
was a five out of five. And our hypothesis there is because there's so much societal pressure on women to be self-effacing and humble and hang back and be modest and wait till they're certain rather than raising their hand at the first opportunity like men on average do. That if a woman says she's a five, first of all, she's probably gonna have higher EQ and social like men on average do. That if a woman says she's a five,
是5分中的5分。我们的假设是，因为社会对女性有很大的压力，要求她们谦逊、退让、保持文静、等到确定之后再行动，而不是像平均而言的男人那样在第一时间举手。如果一个女人说她是5分，首先，她可能平均会有更高的情商和社交洞察力。
first of all, she's probably gonna have higher EQ and social perceptiveness on average. And second, she's gonna be amazing. And indeed, that's what we see. You know, we had Adam Grant from the Wharton School on Hidden Brain some weeks ago talking about his work. And I know he's been someone who has been in your orbit as well.
其次，她会非常了不起。确实，这就是我们所看到的。你知道，几周前我们请了沃顿商学院的亚当·格兰特来到Hidden Brain谈论他的工作。我知道他也是一直在你周围圈子里的人。
And one of the provocative ideas he discussed with me is the idea that many of the greatest innovators do not actually put their hands up and volunteer. So Michelangelo apparently ran in the opposite direction when he was first asked to paint the Sistine Chapel. Martin Luther King Jr. had no plans to be the leader of the civil rights movement. These were folks who were drafted
他和我讨论的一个富有启发性的观点是，许多最伟大的创新者实际上并没有举手自愿。米开朗基罗显然在第一次被邀请画西斯廷礼拜堂时朝相反的方向跑去。小马丁·路德·金根本没有计划成为民权运动的领导者。这些人都是被征召入伍
and then suddenly discovered that they could do amazing things. How do you do this as a company? How do you find talent that isn't looking to be found? That's a great question. This is part of what we look for when I said we look for emergent leadership. People who when they see a problem kind of step in and make it better. And we actually did a piece of work on this. It was inspired by an article actually about Shane Vadeye when he was playing for the Houston Rockets and Michael Lewis who wrote the article observed, hey, whenever this guy's on the court,
然后突然发现自己能做出不起的事情。作为一家公司，你该如何做到这一点？你如何找到那些不想被发现的人才？这是一个好问题。这正是我们寻找我所说的“突发性领导力”时寻找的一部分。当人们看到问题时，会介入并使其变得更好的人。我们实际上在这方面做了一些工作。它的灵感其实来自于一篇关于肖恩·巴蒂尔在休斯敦火箭队效力时的文章，写这篇文章的迈克尔·刘易斯观察到：嘿，每当这家伙在球场上时，
the whole team plays better and performs better, but nobody's looking at him as the star. And then eventually people realize there was something there. So similarly, we did a piece of work called Project Aristotle trying to figure out what makes teams effective and where does innovation come from and what we found was you can put a bunch of work called Project Aristotle trying to figure out what makes teams effective. And where does innovation come from? And what we found was, you can put a bunch of stars together and that doesn't mean the
整个团队的比赛表现都会更好，但没有人把他看作明星。然后最终人们意识到那里有些名堂。同样地，我们做了一项名为“亚里士多德计划”的工作，试图弄清楚是什么让团队变得高效，创新来自哪里，我们发现你可以把一群明星放在一起，这并不意味着
team's going to be a superstar team. What instead is important is a number of factors, but the underlying one is psychological safety. And if you have a team where there's psychological safety, what happens is, these people who normally hang back, who, as you say, and as Adam says, often have the best ideas, they feel okay coming forward. And they raise their hands in teams with high psychological safety, which you can measure and improve, they outperform teams with low psychological safety. And this is particularly important when you're talking about diversity.
这个团队会成为超级明星团队。真正重要的是许多因素，但潜在的一个因素是心理安全感。如果你有一个拥有心理安全感的团队，会发生什么呢？那些通常退缩的人（正如你所说，正如亚当所说，他们通常拥有最好的想法）会觉得站出来是可以接受的。他们在具有高心理安全感的团队中举手（你可以衡量并改善这种安全感），他们的表现优于心理安全感低的团队。当你谈论多元化时，这一点尤其重要。
Because it also turns out that teams with high psychological safety benefit tremendously from diversity and teams without it, don't. I do want to ask about diversity because Google, like many other tech companies, and in fact, many other companies in general, has struggled to boost levels of diversity among its workforce, especially when it comes to women and African Americans and Latinos. What are you doing in people operations specifically besides going to historically back colleges, for instance? What are you, what are the things that you have discovered that work in terms of bringing
因为事实也证明，拥有高心理安全感的团队从多元化中获益匪浅，而没有它的团队则不然。我确实想问关于多元化的事情，因为谷歌和其他许多科技公司一样，实际上与许多其他一般公司一样，一直在努力提高其员工队伍中的多元化水平，特别是在女性、非裔美国人和拉丁裔方面。除了去历史上的黑人学院之外，你在人事运营方面具体在做些什么？你发现了哪些方法在吸引
those people to Google and more important than that, keeping them in Google? What we see is that one of the big constraints is our initial starting conditions. So you know, a couple of years ago, the company was something like 16 on the engineering side. So half the company is engineering. We were about 16 or 17 percent female. It turns out if we wanted to get to 50 percent female, we would have to hire only women for the next six years. And so that starting condition makes it really hard to make progress as quickly as we'd
这些人来到谷歌以及更重要的是让他们留在谷歌方面是有效的？我们看到的是，最大的制约因素之一是我们最初的起点条件。所以你知道，几年前，公司在工程方面大约占16%（公司的一半是工程）。我们大约有16%或17%是女性。事实证明，如果我们想达到50%的女性，我们在接下来的六年里必须只招收女性。所以这种初始条件使得我们很难像我们希望的那样以极快的速度取得进展，
like because it turns out even though I'd love to hire only women, it's illegal to do so. So what are we doing? Part of it is pipeline. You got to work on that. So we partner with colleges. There's K through 12 programs. We developed a kid called CS First
因为事实证明，尽管我很乐意只招收女性，但这样做是违法的。所以我们在做什么？一部分是人才管道。你必须在这方面努力。所以我们与大学合作。有K-12（从幼儿园到高中）项目。我们开发了一个名为“CS First”的小孩项目，
by basically hiring 25 teachers and going to a school district in North Carolina and saying, come up with something. Do whatever you want. Use them, however you see fit. And they developed the CS first curriculum that Bill de Blasios using in New York that's now a quarter million kids have been through. So that's one, getting more people into the field. The second is getting better at recruiting and making sure people see that it's sort of a good place to be and building networks because some of this
方法是基本上雇佣25名教师，去北卡罗来纳州的一个学区说：“想出点东西来。随心所欲地做。用他们，以你们认为合适的方式。”他们开发了CS First课程，比尔·德布拉西奥正在纽约使用这门课程，现在已有二十万儿童学过。所以这是一个，让更多的人进入这个领域。第二是改进招聘，确保人们看到这是一个好地方，并建立网络，因为其中一部分
is, you know, if you're African American, you don't immediately think I got to get to Silicon Valley, right? It's not sort of the first thing. In part, in large part, because the industry hasn't been great, but also because there aren't centers of gravity there are big communities, and we need to fix that. The third is changing our culture inside the company. The tech industry historically has not been very welcoming to women, to blacks, to Latinos. It's only the last few years it's gotten a better place for people who are LGBT. And so we built an unconscious bias training program.
是，如果你是非裔美国人，你不会立即想到我必须去硅谷，对吧？这通常不是第一选择。部分原因（很大程度上）是因为这个行业一直不够好，但也因为那里没有重力中心或大型社区，我们需要解决这个问题。第三是改变我们公司内部的文化。科技行业历史上对女性、黑人和拉丁裔一直不是很友好。直到最近几年，对于LGBT群体来说，它才成为一个更好的地方。所以我们建立了一个无意识偏见培训项目。
And what we've seen is that a greater percentage of Googlers now not only understand discrimination and bias, but they say it is my personal obligation to take action to make this place better. Because ideally what happens is the onus for addressing this shouldn't be on the parties that are in the minority. It should be on the majority to take action and fix things like microaggressions and hiring processes and culture. Lazlo Bach is head of Google's people operations, is also the author of the book, Work Rules,
我们所看到的是，现在有更高比例的谷歌员工不仅理解歧视和偏见，而且他们说：“我有个人义务采取行动让这个地方变得更好。”因为理想情况下，解决这个问题的责任不应该落在少数群体身上。多数群体应该采取行动解决诸如微歧视、招聘流程和文化之类的问题。拉斯洛·巴克是谷歌人事运营主管，也是《工作规则》一书的作者。
Insights from Inside Google, that will transform how you live and lead. The Hidden Brain podcast is produced by Karam Agarakaleson, Maggie Penman and Max Nestrak. Find more Hidden Brain on Facebook, Twitter and and Instagram, and hear my stories on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vedantum, and this is NPR. If you like what we do on Hidden Brain, you should take a listen to Latino USA. Host Maria Hinoosa brings you interviews and stories with a fresh perspective. You'll hear from artists and immigrants, abuelos and others what changing the American political, social and creative
来自谷歌内部的洞察将改变你的生活和领导方式。《Hidden Brain》播客由卡拉姆·阿加拉卡尔森、玛吉·彭曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克的制作。在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注更多《Hidden Brain》的内容，并在你当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。我是尚卡尔·维丹图，这是NPR。如果你喜欢我们在《Hidden Brain》节目中所做的一切，你应该听听《Latino USA》。主持人玛丽亚·希诺萨为你带来具有全新视角的人物专访和故事。你将听到艺术家和移民、祖父母以及其他正在改变美国政治、社会和创作
landscape. Find LatinoUSA now on the NPR1 app and at npr.org slash podcast. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
景观的人的声音。现在可以在NPR1应用程序和npr.org/podcast上找到《LatinoUSA》。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。